a lot of people start off and
they do well for themselves very few get
valued at one and a half billion dollars
we're eight years old we're like i said
half a billion dollars in revenue
so jim sharp was just a cool domain that
i found online i bought it off godaddy
it was about three pound fifty
it was you know the whole startup cost
twenty pounds thirty dollars
jim chart story people assumed that it
was like this one thing that i've tried
and it went incredibly well
13 14 years old and starting gym shark
at 19 i
started like six or seven maybe even
more than that different businesses and
websites
all of which which failed miserably when
was it when you said i think this could
really have some legs and turn into a
real business
the body power expo now before the event
we were selling on average two to three
hundred pound a day worth of product
we turned all the website off we thought
right we'll kick it back off monday when
the event's finished
the first half an hour after we turned
the website back on
we sold 30 000 pounds of product
now we're on to something special if we
know anything about the younger
generation right they want to buy a
brand that really resonates with their
core values and i think jim chart does
that
to all the young entrepreneurs out there
if you need an inspiration today's story
is going to do it for you my guest today
ben francis the founder of gymshark
which you've probably heard of jim shark
it's a brand
predominantly big in europe but he's
bringing it to north america and if you
go to the gym nowadays you'll see the
brand
i think in august the company was valued
around 1.545 billion dollars
and he is the 70 owner of the company
making him
in a billion dollar mark at 28 years old
and he started it at 19 years old
with that being said ben francis thank
you so much for being a guest on
vacation
thanks patrick thanks for having me i'm
looking forward to uh talking to you
today
what a great story you got by the way so
going back take me back to the people
that don't know the story obviously i've
watched it
i know your story many know your story
but think about the story people that
don't know your story
how did you go from who you were at in
high school
what things you witnessed with your
parents uh business when he
you know risked his mom's house to
eventually you
you know messing around with different
things and then eventually starting jim
shark
yeah so back to be honest so back in
high school
in fact i'll tell you i'll go back
before even there so my
my grandfather ran his own business and
i think this is where
and by the way both of my grandparents
ran their own business i think this is
where i got my sort of inspiration for
business and entrepreneurship came from
because i did work experience
i'm sure you do something similar over
in the states i think it's like 13 14
years old
um and he would essentially tell me
stories about how he'd started the
business and sort of risked everything
to make it work
so i think i think i was sort of like
exposed to that idea of risk
particularly financial risk from a young
age so to be honest that's where i
really got the inspiration to be
involved in business
um i feel like as well with the sort of
jim chart story people assume that it
was like this
one thing that i've tried and it went
incredibly well
between that work experience at 13 14
years old and starting gymshark at 19 i
started like six or seven maybe even
more than that different businesses and
websites
all of which which failed miserably um
before jim shark was the one that you
know
essentially blew up now let me ask you
when i when i watch you speak
i feel fire in your spirit your eyes
your energy
have you always been a pretty serious
guy i mean listen we all have a
you know softer side we're around our
family members we're comfortable we're
loose we're
can just kind of be ourselves but are
you generally a pretty serious guy
yourself
um i guess so i mean you're right like
obviously
around friends and family i think you're
right everyone chills out i think
when it comes to stuff like this like i
love i just love making things and i've
spoken about this
previously and with gymshark it's like
my life's work i feel like i've got the
best job in the world i get to create
all the things that i love which are
centered around my passion
with a bunch of amazing people so i
guess it is
quite serious to me because again it's
my life's work and it's something that's
really really important to me
if i was in high school with you you and
i were friends at 14 15 years old who
was ben
very different to what i am now very
very very different i think at high
school i
thought i was laughing with one of my
mates the other day like at that age you
think that you're like grown up you
think that you can go on
and take the take on the world but i was
very quiet to be honest very
chill very relaxed um certainly wasn't
like the most popular kid in school but
wasn't massively fussed about that i was
massively into sport
gaming and i was just fascinated with
computers websites
programming and everything that came
with it really
interesting was your relationship with
your parents a good relationship easy
going relationship not a lot of fights
not a lot of trying to do your own thing
was it a supportive environment yes so
very very supportive so that my parents
were
very opinionated so i remember when i so
i worked
incredibly hard to get into university
right i was the first person in my
family to ever get into university
it was an amazing opportunity for me and
i was so incredibly proud and my mum
sort of had to really
really sort of sit me down and talk to
me about concentrating in school to
essentially get into university so like
i said when i got in
they were so proud so for 18 months
later for me to call them and say
hey i'm gonna drop out of university
they were a little bit
concerned at that point um albeit
gymshark at that point was doing quite
well
but as soon as i'd made the decision and
i said right that is it that's a
decision that's my mind made
they 100 supported me and there was
never a point where they sort of said
should you have really dropped out of
university maybe when things are a bit
more difficult later on so
they're incredibly supportive
interesting that's that's
great to hear uh in high school was math
your favorite subject like did math come
easy to you was it
writing was it science what came easy to
you so this is the thing right so when i
when i was at school in the uk we do
sort of a certain set of exams up to the
age of 16 and then you had the option to
leave school or go back into sort of
like
at what we call college um i didn't
actually do that well up until the age
of 16
and the school didn't actually want me
to stay on through 17 and 18.
now i was really lucky someone dropped
out and they ended up taking me back in
um on the basis that i did in english
literature
so i never enjoyed it i was never i
didn't think i was good at it
but for whatever reason i was really
good with writing you know and
i guess english lit lit basically so i
did english
uh business and i t but i adored it to
be honest
you adored it okay business it's fun
it's funny though because business i
didn't i liked it but i didn't love it i
found myself frustrated by it in a lot
of ways i learned a lot of quite
you know great basics uh building and
starting a
limited company and things like that but
i think i was always frustrated because
i wanted to do it
rather than write about it that makes a
lot of sense and you definitely ended up
doing it so
walk me through now your uh uh
the moment where you and your buddy
lewis are sitting there and you're
saying what if we start our own company
called
you know a gym shark and you know
how that led to you meeting steven 2015
kind of give me the history of how that
takes place takes place
so i said i loved it and i was really
really lucky
actually because in in growing up
so i grew up in i still live here i grew
up in a part of the uk called the west
midlands so we're right in the middle
it's it's basically the industrial
powerhouse of of the uk
it's it's you know nowhere near as
wealthy as london it's just sort of a
very
it's a very i love it here but it's not
the wealthiest part of the uk
so we didn't have massive access to some
of the amazing software that's more
readily available today
now when i took this it class i didn't
know what it was at the time but it gave
me access to the adobe creative suite
and that's where you had dreamweaver so
you could make websites illustrator for
graphics photoshop and
i didn't realize at the time how lucky i
was to have access to this
these products but they literally
completely changed my life because as a
young creative
all of a sudden i could create the
things that i was imagining in my head
so started making all these different
websites and iphone apps just because it
was something that i thought was cool
um and then after a while i wanted to
make a website that would transact
because everything else i've made didn't
actually sell anything
so i i had a friend who worked at a
supplement company at the time
and i said to him listen i want to make
a website that's going to transact i
need to know how much it's going to cost
me to buy some supplements off you
because
at the time i was massively into the gym
i was massively into fitness my dream
was to be like a
bodybuilder and um and he said to me
it's going to cost i think it was 8
000 pounds for a purchase of supplements
to sell on the website
now i'd never even heard of eight
thousand pound let alone seen eight
thousand pound at that point i was
working
uh i think it was like four pound eight
in out eighty an hour at pizza hut so
it was like it just was unfathomable for
me to be able to have that
so what we thought we would do is just
make a website that would transact and
then drop ship supplements
so for anyone that's watching that
doesn't know what drop shipping is it's
basically
you load the website up with a load of
product that you don't actually own
someone comes onto your website and buys
it and you basically ship it from
another vendor and it goes straight to
the consumer and you make a small margin
now the margin was tiny so i'll never
actually forget this we had our first
sale it took
three months i think to get the first
sale um
and it was a 50 pound supplement of
which two pounds was profit
now to any commercial business person
two pound profit
on a 50 quid sale is is not particularly
great and you have to do ridiculous
scale for
for that to be worth anything but the
aim of the game was just to be involved
in fitness any way that i could
and also build a website that would
transact and you know this did it so
i was like literally running around my
bedroom buzzing with the fact that we'd
actually made a website that transacted
so and that that was how it started
really and it was it was super organic
right the the name jim shark
because at the time i'd made so many
websites previously to me this was
another one i didn't know it would be
anything great so jim sharp was just a
cool domain i found online it was short
i bought it off godaddy it was about
three pound fifty
it was you know the whole startup cost
bearing in mind everything was drop
shipped and
and um our startup cost must have been
20 pounds 30 you know it's it's it's
like
nothing so um yeah
that's essentially how the business
started what was your role and what did
lewis do was it was louis cmo
ceo ceo you were ceo
cfo who who handled what whose strengths
were what so at the time because it was
just it wasn't really
it wasn't like a business as such it was
just a case of let's go off and make
this so
we didn't really have roles now as we
fast forward that's when the business
developed and roll sort of occurred so
like i said we were drop shipping these
supplements and it was it was going okay
there'd be a sale every few days or so
because the margins were so small you'd
be making like
you know four or five pounds a week
maybe in terms of profits
so after a while and going back to sort
of look there was there was this
i guess something that was so fortunate
and lucky that just the stars had to
align
so in birmingham there's a place called
the nec which is the national exhibition
center
now every year they would have one of
the best fitness events in the world
called body power
and for me and all my friends that
wanted to be bodybuilders and basically
fitness people who just
followed that youtube scene massively
and the bodybuilding scene we'd check in
with olympia every year
that was like our one opportunity to see
these amazing people from around the
world normally from
you know the us and places like that um
so every year we would go to body power
just to be amongst the fitness champions
of the world
and we were all walking around me and my
mates and i'll never forget this because
i had to sort of run off to pizza hook
because my shifts would normally start
at five so we got there saturday morning
spent the day there
and you're looking at all these people
in all the fitness clothes and the
stringer vest and the more the old
school bodybuilding stuff
and then we try it on but because we
were more you know slender in our
physique than the huge bodybuilders it
would like
drown us because they would be so
massive so we just thought to ourselves
like why don't we just
try and make our own um now conveniently
at the time
my nan was basically doing a curtain
making course
so i thought to myself why don't we buy
a sewing machine we bought a screen
printer
essentially with all of our savings and
we started to basically hand
make clothes to be honest more for
ourselves than anything else and then
happened to put them on the website
um i think that coincided with the fact
that we loved youtube
still do right so haven't watched telly
since i was very very young that it
would always be around football or
soccer in the states
um i i literally just thought right
let's let's send
this product to that we love to some of
our heroes on youtube and see what they
think
and those guys started to wear it more
and more it you know built up
i guess a bit of a brand and people
started buying our clothes online
so so was there a strength that lewis
played versus you because the reason why
i asked this question is a lot of times
there's other friends where you know
they're in college together they're
thinking about doing something together
and they're you know
when i go and speak at universities i'll
typically say rather than thinking about
you know find your passion on what you
want to do but also recruit a good
group of people that have opposing
strengths to build your business with
was there a strength he had that was
different than yours and what was your
strength versus his
yeah so i think so at this point i don't
think we'd really work that out i think
we just had
and the thing that i think the thing
that really worked with us is we were
just almost ferociously
passionate about what we were doing both
of us so to be fair as well just
for context we're 18 19 20 years old at
this point
all of our friends would often go out
and they'd be at university we were the
two that decided to go to university but
stay at home
so we were the two i think in our area
who were quite happy to sort of
sacrifice everything else
for this dream now as it started to
develop over the
the years and we started to have revenue
and build our business
we definitely found sort of um
i guess i had different strengths but
listen lewis ended up moving on from the
business a few years later so i don't
think the cohesion was maybe as good as
what it should have been whereas later
on when steve joined the business about
three years after we started i think
that's where we really found cohesion
because
mine and steve's strengths are
completely opposite in terms of he's
very much your more i guess how you'd
see more of a typical business person in
terms of very organized a great people
person a manager experienced
where i was a lot more around creative
products and so on and i really had to
learn
the other skills so i think that's where
that cohesion started to begin
ben are you today the ceo or today
you're the chairman of the board and
steve's the ceo
yeah so steve's the ceo today and that
was a decision that we made
a few years ago and i'm sat as sort of a
chief product officer
role but i tend to jump around different
areas of the business even though you're
a 70
majority shareholder you're the chief
product officer applaud you for
i applaud you for doing that by the way
the first sale that was made after
putting up the three months of the
website where you made two dollars of
profits
did you ever track the customer down to
see how they find you
and what they bought and why they bought
it on your site i did
because it's funny enough because they
they were from the local area so they'd
heard of us
um i mean they'd live you know 10 20
minutes i sort of know of them we're not
sort of friends as such but i think they
just found out about it
in the gym in the local gyms very cool
at what point did you did you kind of
have an idea that you're up to something
big like when was it when you said you
know
i think this could really have some legs
and turn into a real business
so to be honest it happened quite
quickly
so we i mentioned the body power expo
we i was at that expo and this is when
the business was very very small
and i had a it was like a
good a proper proper innate gut feeling
that we had to be there the following
year bearing in mind at this point we
had no product to be there i just
thought we have to be here
now when i think that was may 2011
we were walking around as customers and
i just thought right we've got to be
here i went straight to the the
organizers stand and i said
i want to stand here next year what does
it cost i think it was three thousand
pound for the entry level stand
you know just again more money than we'd
ever seen but i thought right fine
we've got 12 months to pay for it we'll
find out a way of doing it
um so we booked into that and over the
year that's where we had made a lot of
these clothes and we built up the brand
now about two or three months before
that event the people the youtubers that
we've been sending product to who had
over time become friends that we've been
chatting to over skype
we invited them to come to the event
with us so they were all buzzing some of
them were from the states and hadn't
been to the uk before some of them were
from
the uk um and we did this event
and i'm not saying it was a corporate
event because it wasn't but we were just
like listen
there's we're here we want to chat with
the community we would just
love the community more than anything
anyway and almost like by the way if you
want to buy some product then that's
great but after the show we're going to
go to the gym and we can all lift
together and we sort of started to
started to build this community
the show went really really well i was
really happy with how it went we sold
out of a lot of the stuff
but over that weekend because there was
only a small handful of us in the
business
we turned all the website off and we
thought right we'll kick it back off
monday when the event's finished
now what i didn't realize is we'd
stumbled upon i guess the sort of
marketing mix as you call it of today
so we did an in real life event where we
launched new products and no one could
get their hands on it
we had all these youtubers and what are
now called social media influencers
there that were posting on facebook and
youtube and so on and built up this huge
crazy demand and hype that everyone
was looking at um and then like i said
because we were going and lifting with
everyone after the event all of those
guys were following us on social and
sort of falling in love with the brand
and the community that we were all
building together
now after the event i went home and i
was sat at my parents house one
evening and i just sort of turned the
website on thinking nothing would happen
post it on facebook just to let everyone
know that it's back and we're launching
the product that we'd sold at the event
now before the event for context we were
selling on average two to three hundred
pound a day worth of product
again very very proud of where we built
up to we were doing really well
the first half an hour after we turned
the website back on
we sold 30 000 pounds of product
sold out of everything and i was
literally because the stock was set to
infinite i was having to go through each
product and turn it off
um because we had to go and make the
product
and i'll never forget it right it was
about one o'clock in the morning the
website was turned off we have thirty
thousand pound worth of revenue more
revenue
than we'd ever thought was possible in a
30 minute period
and it i was literally sat there on my
own i was thinking okay now
now we're on to something special and
that's when i left pizza that's when i
left university and that's when
everything was just all focused on jim
shaw
wow thirty thousand dollars in first 30
minutes and you're used to doing 300
200 to 300 a day and that takes off to
30 000 you turn off all the products
okay
so when that happens by the way ben how
many shirts have you personally sewn
if you were to say i've sewn that you
know so many shirts how many have you
personally sewn
i could probably work it out
it would it would i would say i would
guess between 500 and a thousand
it wouldn't be massive amounts but at
the time it felt like a lot 500 2
000 and so people still have them and
they'll when we go to events
prior to kobe people would come in some
of the original ones and because there
was always
slight um imperfections in the print or
something and i would sort of instantly
know
and remember it would come back to me as
to that's one of the handmade products
wow
i bet i i mean it's a form of art when
you're designing those because it's
it's limited edition it's it's not
necessarily something that's uh it's a
one-off because
it's being handmade okay so that 30 000
event takes place
in 30 minutes products done you turn
everything off what are you doing next
well this is where it became what i
would call like a real business because
this is where we had to sort of hire
people we were starting to buy in stock
and take more and more risks
um we got our first sort of unit
small warehouse i think it was about 300
square feet
um this is where it became a real
business and this is where i think i
sort of really had to learn
because up until that point it was just
entrepreneurial it was like there was
there was no responsibility for lack of
a better term it would just go where you
want do what you want and it's just grow
grow grow and just go off and enjoy
yourself
now at this point we had to hire people
and responsibility was happening we were
taking on leases
so that was a real sort of learning
curve for me and like i said because i
dropped out of university
and my my job um it was literally a case
of
i'm all in on this so 24 7 i was just
all on all on gymshark and
essentially getting it to grow as
quickly as possible and i think
what we did after that and this is this
is something that at the time came very
natural and it didn't feel like a risk
but looking back i felt it i think it
was a bit of a risk
that one event did well so then we were
like right let's sign up to every event
that we possibly can so we signed up to
body power in birmingham we signed up to
an event called fibo in germany um the
la fit expo in los angeles um
the arnold in columbus ohio melbourne
and we literally just
flew around the entire world going to
all these events we spent
every penny we had and just did event
after event after event whilst the guys
were working back home
uh in that new warehouse that we'd got
to ship out the orders
how did that which one would out of all
the events you went to i mean you know
the
arnold expo quarter million people show
up was there one where you said i was
another one that was a big success
um to be honest they were all really
unique so
i'll always remember every single one of
them to be honest so columbus ohio was
crazy because i didn't realize anywhere
got that cold
so english winters aren't that cold we
went to columbus ohio and i think it was
december
it was freezing but it was incred the
thing that shocked me about that event
was the scale
it was i don't know if you've been it is
huge and the actual event is massive and
they do so much right all the way from
bodybuilding
to there was sort of like people to talk
to around sort of joining the military i
think there was
um all these different sports even
having arnold schwarzenegger that was
just
an amazing thing to see um whereas the
european expos tend to be quite
you have a bodybuilding expo and then
you have maybe a slightly different expo
for different things so
that was amazing but the thing that
really hit me
especially going to places like germany
and the states was
it's almost hit you even harder doing it
in in the international stage because
you just assume that no one
has heard of the brand and it was on
that that was the moment when i'm
starting to realize that wow this social
media thing
this website online direct-to-consumer
e-commerce thing is
it's a global thing now whereas when
you're at home it just feels like a
little bit of a
you know a thing that happens around
where you are man a lot of people do
drop shipping a lot of people create
sites a lot of people sell
shirts a lot of people do uh not
necessarily what you guys are doing at
this scale but a lot but a lot of people
start off
and they do well for themselves very few
get valued at one and a half billion
dollars
of a business where people around the
world are talking and they have
millions of loyal followers what would
you say was the biggest differentiator
between you guys and everybody else
so i think there was a few i think now
as the business grew i think we built an
amazing culture so internally we've got
a brilliant culture and a great balance
of people that are really trying to
create you know the next big thing in
the next special thing but equally those
who are building a really robust
business because you'll know right when
you get to scale
it's all well and good but if you're not
built on solid foundations
it's it's sort of irrelevant and to be
honest i had a fair few learning curves
myself so
i mentioned the entrepreneurial phase
during the entrepreneurial phase
which i think is the more quintessential
view of what an entrepreneur is it's
like
you have your vision and you move
towards it and regardless of what anyone
says around you
you there's that's irrelevant right you
move forward to where you think it
should be and for me it was about
grabbing the business by the scruff of
the neck to where i thought it should be
no matter what
then all of a sudden almost overnight
you build a team
and you can't just grab the business
around the school for the nectar where
you want to go away when you've got a
team because
you'll start to alienate those
individuals so i had a few sort of
wake-up moments which was like oh god
now i need to shift my like i need to
change for the business to become
someone that's more of a you know a team
player and a leader in that respect and
to be fair i learned a lot of that from
steve
and then the business grows and grows
and grows and now the business is at a
stage where
i mean last calendar year we did over
half a billion dollars in revenue
we've got offices in colorado and uk and
mauritius in hong kong
all of a sudden now for me it's all
about right what's the long-term vision
i'm a lot more strategic i need to think
outside the box i need to try and really
think about what's next and be one step
ahead all the time so i think
me adapting and everyone in the company
adapted i think is powerful i think
we've got an incredible culture which
again is incredibly powerful
um i also think that we
took risks where other people wouldn't
so i go back to those events
we'd saved over time up to having i
think we had about a million pounds in
the bank
which that was at 21 22 years old
and we spent every single penny on it on
growth every single penny on the
community every single penny on meeting
as many people as possible and
and that's all the athletes and the
staff and myself and i would always meet
as many people as we can
so i think the business model helped as
well i think the culture helped
and ultimately i think we have a really
great product
and i think that's we can invest even
further into our product because we're
built in a way that i think the future
of brands will be built
so you'll know that during yesteryear
some of the larger brands would be built
in a way where they would build as much
product as they can to put into as many
stores as they can to please as many
people as they can
and that was sort of the the route to
success during the high street era
whereas now this entirely new landscape
that we're all a part of
you can create a genuine purposeful
product that's built for a specific
community
and you can reach them across the world
and if we know anything about the
younger generation right they want to
buy a brand that really resonates with
their core values and i think jim chart
does that
ben uh how hard were you did you were
you and uh louis or any of your friends
in the partying scene or no
no not really um listen there's i think
there's the odd thing that you'll go out
here and there but particularly when we
were younger we were
absolutely dead sure and this is where
we wanted to spend our time and this is
where we wanted to be
what kind of what kind of schedule did
you have what kind of a work schedule
did you have
so again to be honest patrick this is
something i'm only just learning now
so it varies massively but it would be
it would be your typical sort of
entrepreneurial
thing right you would wake up and you
would just work and you would work and
work and work and then i would gym and i
would go to bed
and then as the business starts to scale
it's brilliant because you can literally
outsource your weaknesses
so one of my weaknesses is like i'm not
very organized
so all of a sudden now i wake up and i
have like a set of train tracks through
the day which i can work through which
are sort of provided for me
but during the startup phase it
genuinely is a case of
being dead set on your vision working
incredibly hard sometimes through the
night if you need to
and just moving forward no matter what
you said your parents
whether it was your dad or your parents
they were big on mindset what were some
of the mindset they were telling you
about you constantly talk about mindset
yeah so so my so my mom is
incredibly hard working so she works in
the nhs here and she has done
since i was born and obviously before
that so i think from from my mom i
learned
just work incredibly hard so as a kid
she would work nights she would work all
night she'd come home
take me to school sleep whilst we were
at school and then pick us up after
school
my dad's incredibly hard working as well
and you're right he would always talk
about mindset so we
i loved sport growing up i loved
football i loved soccer
um and he would always say it's all
about sort of mental strength it's all
about your mind
you know listen to the advice that
people give you you can learn something
from everyone that you meet
and he would always sort of put a little
asterisk next to that and say but
remember
you choose which advice you apply to
yourself um
it's almost like thinking of your mind
as like a computer and you choose the
sort of updates that you wish to patch
into your mind and i think that's
been really powerful because i've had a
lot of brilliant advice i've also had
a fair bit of bad advice too so you sort
of choose what you take on and you know
develop yourself into
and into who you want to be you you said
your mom
talked to you about concentration
because you said uh
up until 16 years old you know you
didn't have good grades and you learned
how to get good grades how did
how did your mom work with you uh it's
very hard to
be concentrating at that age especially
when you're saying you're not a
organized person and a lot of
entrepreneurs type a personalities may i
mean you're an introvert yourself you've
talked about it openly
but how did your mom work with you on
concentration
i think she always had i think she still
does even like i said so she doesn't
understand
the ins and outs of jim shark and what
what i do and maybe what
i did when i was younger but i think she
she she knew that i could do like great
things but i think her confidence in me
sort of helped give me confidence so
when she sort of said to me listen you
can do really well at school
if you put your mind to it then all of a
sudden i'm like well
you know what i'm i'm gonna give it a go
then and i think that confidence really
helped
got it last but not least your vision
you said the
the vision is to compete with a uh nike
or an adidas
or under armour where are you at now
with the vision of jim shark
listen i i think maybe i'm less about
scale
because if we want scale i think we
could get it
in terms of we could sell jim shark into
many high street stores and we could
double triple
quadruple the business in a very very
quick time frame
for me it's about building what i think
the future of brands will be and as i've
mentioned before it's a
community-focused brand
that has you know you know a distinct
value behind it and i think
that's where i want to go so it's less
about scale but it's about creating the
best fitness brand in the world
and i think that comes with being a
direct to consumer brand a brand that is
agile and lean so we can invest into the
community and in the product rather than
in
you know thousands of shops around the
world so
we do we're doing incredibly well listen
we've we're eight years old
we're like i said half a billion dollars
in revenue we've been the uk's fastest
growing business from a top-line
perspective but we also had
we had won the award a couple of years
ago for the one of the uk's fastest
growing businesses from a profit
perspective as well
so many businesses scale the top line
but often not the bottom line so for us
to do both i think is really powerful
um and it means that we can invest in
the long term of this brand in the long
term of this business and we're really
focused on those long term decisions
yeah it's pretty exciting what you've
done man you know kudos to you for
building a story like the one you have
kai loda is the one that uh recommended
you to have you on valuetainment and
kai's from norway
and he says pat ben is
everywhere in norway everywhere in
europe everywhere
we go we hear about jim shark and i
looked up your story i said that's a
fantastic story
let's have him on on valuetainment so
with that being said ben thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
so thank you for having me patrick thank
you i appreciate it you got it buddy
you know what's crazy is somewhere in
the world some 17 year old kid
is going to be watching this video being
inspired by ben francis to start the
next gym
shark that will find that about 10 years
from now if you watch it accordingly so
if you're somebody
that's watching this and you were
inspired by ben make sure to share
this with others that you may know who
may be a teenager and say listen
son brother nephew niece watch this
video this kid could inspire you
because what ben has done the world
needs to know about his story having
said that if you enjoyed this interview
with ben i'm curious to know what you
took away from it
comment below i think you would also
enjoy the interview i did with chip
wilson
the founder of lululemon how he went
from zero
to building nearly a 15 billion dollar
company with a net worth of 4 billion
plus
take care everybody
[Music]